all right so it was a
troubling week for the national football
league and the news is still coming in
from the tennessee titans
a week after
their facility was shut down they're
still generating positives which tells
us more than i think we ever really
understood about the incubation period
of this disease the new england patriots
i'm told continue to get negative tests
in the aftermath of the news that cam
newton tested positive on friday with a
result that came back saturday morning
see there's two types of tests chris
there's the point of care test where you
do it right there you take the test you
get the result in a matter of of minutes
at least within an hour you don't have
to send it out to a lab then there's the
test samples they harvest on site send
them off to a lab and you wait and i was
told yesterday how long you wait depends
upon how close you are to the lab they
got to put it in a van they got to take
it somewhere they got to get into the
lab and once the lab gets it they can
test it fairly quickly but the lag is
driven in large part by how far you are
so sometimes you find out at night
sometimes you find out the next morning
but what i've been told is the patriots
found out that yesterday's sunday
samples that were sent off site for
testing all negative so
the good news is and i haven't heard
anything about the chiefs you know and
people are like well you know why aren't
folks focused on the chiefs they have a
positive player too in jordan ta'amu
practice squad quarterback and yeah the
same potential for an outbreak in kansas
city as there is in new england both
teams so far
clean other than the two who tested
positive both teams do
to play tonight at seven o'clock eastern
to make up the game that was postponed
from yesterday after the news emerged
that the two positives this just shows
you how crazy it all can be how changes
need to be made quickly and how how
tenuous it ultimately is going to be to
get 256 games in chris yeah i mean it's
um
it's it's a little scary it brought us
back to reality this last week for sure
i i think i mean listen
everything in our country brought us
back to reality i think a little last
week i mean no doubt and i'm not even
you know whether it's though no well i
don't know
i don't know do people do you really
think people have understood because i
think all it does it's another instance
of where we can line up in our two
tribes
and shout profanity each other man
no that no facts are changing anything
even with the president in the hospital
for three days with covet 19 it's not
changing anyone's view on
on whether masks work or don't work or
whether whether you're a karen or a beta
because you wear a mask and it's just
it's stupid to me nothing's going to
change our view on it well well that's
we're hardened in our position okay i
don't know those people are stupid i
don't know what else to say
you're stupid i do you don't like it's
like it's like if you were gonna have a
conversation with bill belichick and go
i'm not gonna really listen to you about
football i'm not sure about your
credentials you don't know i mean that's
what you're doing to people who are
saying to wear a mask sorry
and the guy who mocked it of course
karma came back all right so now it's
everywhere though forget that i mean
it's starting to pop up everywhere
through our country even here in
connecticut we're starting to see it a
little bit more and it's scary it is it
seems like it's not going to be you know
we're not gonna be able to avoid this
all year long and mike i come back to
what you said last week i know i said it
last night and i meant to give you
credit on the show when i said it i mean
i i think you're right we're getting
towards the part of
we're gonna have to have 32 bubbles i i
really do i mean just as you listen to
the experts we're getting into fall
season last year flu season was horrible
to begin with before corona was here so
now you're gonna have the combination of
that and lowered immune systems and
things like that and i'm just scared
that we won't be able to get it done
unless teams start to kind of create
their own hotel bubble that way and
that's the only way to ensure the safety
the challenge for the nfl players
association which is constantly engaged
in collective bargaining with the the
league and it's not just something that
happens every time they do a new deal
there are issues that come up all the
time and there was a huge issue that
came up in july how are we going to
negotiate the protocols for
playing this season in the pandemic
and i i respect the fact that you always
try to get something for your
constituency when management wants you
to do something but there's a point
where you just have to realize it's in
our best interest to go along with this
the union needs to say we will go get
into the bubbles the numbers are going
up and the
the best way to look at it and i had
someone explain it like this to me over
the weekend
in every nfl building there are 170
stories not that they're 170 stories
tall there are 170 people who have their
own lives their own tale they go home we
don't know how they're potentially
getting infected are they going out and
doing dumb things like derek carr and
friends last monday night are they just
going home and there happens to be
somebody in the house who was out that
day who accidentally got infected you
you don't know right what these people
are doing when they leave so the only
way to avoid that is to put everybody in
a hotel hotel to practice practice it's
a hotel we've been banging this drum
over and over again but it's getting
worse
and somebody said to me
last night i can't remember who it was
that basically if if there's
one more of these
one more incident that's when the nfl is
going to why are you waiting for one
more you know one more is going to
happen why are you waiting for it do it
now
agreed i mean i i think we're getting
very close to that i mean if cam
newton's not enough of a
a name to pop up if the tennessee titans
where we're having positive tests daily
for what is it six days in a row now
mike was it five either way i mean
you know that's scary what what are you
gonna do i mean yeah i mean the titans
right now and we're not sure they're
going to play next week they might miss
two games how is that going to work how
is that going to be fair to other teams
uh so that's where i agree with you mike
i really do
patriots taking two planes today to
kansas city why one plane has the 20 or
so people who were in close contact with
cam newton the other plane has everyone
else which just underscores the
incubation period is the doughnut hole
the unfixable doughnut hole in this
problem for the nfl because you can be
generating negative negative negative
until the day you give a sample that we
find out tomorrow was positive and you
shed virus for a whole day on everyone
else and then they start into the
incubation period
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports